hello i'm matthew and i'm a tasty
producer today i have five minutes to
explain to my friend joyce how to cook a
complicated classic dish chicken cordon
bleu my name is joyce and i'm certainly
not a professional chef at the end of
this i want to make a dish that my
family and friends would be impressed by
once joy starts cooking i can't touch
anything i can't talk i can't help her
she's completely on her own except for
two exceptions if she's feeling lost
doesn't know what to do she has one
opportunity to ask me for help and on my
end if i see she's about to royally
screw something up i can use my one
opportunity to save her butt here's your
notebook yeah are you ready i got it
what we're gonna do is you're gonna take
this chicken and you're gonna season it
with salt pepper garlic powder and onion
powder then take a chicken breast put it
on the cutting board cover it with
parchment paper and you're going to
gently pound it so it's so fast he's
rambling i don't know what he's saying
the reason why you're doing cheese ham
cheese is so then the cheese might melt
it's like blue i twist the sides like
you're making a tootsie roll you've got
345 okay
so many steps to it there's like a way
to like make a tootsie roll like how am
i going to make this dish this is wet so
the dry will stick to the wet chicken
then it's dry which will stick to the
eggs and the eggs will stick to this 90
seconds
i could only write so fast i'm a
millennial like we type i can type
faster than i can right you're making a
root you're going to take the milk and
you're going to pour it in and whisk it
the liquid should come up to a simmer
salt pepper parmesan cheese and the
mustard stir that in and then it should
be cheesy mustardy delicious and that
will get poured over your chicken when
you're done
it's a lot when all this is over i have
to pretend whatever joyce makes is my
own i have to bring it to the rest of
the tasty office to try my own
reputation is on the line okay take
chicken
oh and i put all the seasoning then i
put the parchment paper so i'm supposed
to season this in here how would my
grandma do this you just take the slab
and rub it all around
look at he's judging me uh these spices
were perfectly measured out for her but
she's just taking tiny little bits and
like sprinkling it on i don't know if
this is seasoned all the way i want to
help so much how bad am i doing not oh
like can't say she's not being bad no
okay oh i can't do that okay
let me smell it
oh that's seasoned it's not a big deal i
think it'll still be fine the chicken
will still taste good she's all right
i'm not going to use my lifeline yet all
right so what is yours going to do next
wash your hands because sanitary reasons
i'll be right back
they finally gave me a blunt object to
hit this meat with and i'm going to
think about every x i've ever had in my
life
[Music]
she could be better oh my gosh i'mma get
that fatty part over there cause she's
still looking pumped
she don't care this is looking good she
put the parchment paper beneath the
chicken and was pounding the raw chicken
with the mallet itself i mean it'll kind
of work but it's not what it's supposed
to be there for so back to my notes over
here cheese home cheese usually i would
wash my hands again but that's a little
aggressive i like to wash my hands a lot
i went to nursing school is that enough
ham
i'm a double ham on them i'm rebelling
dad and then once again the true love of
my life cheese now we gotta roll it
we gotta roll it like a roll up wait i
roll it with the plastic paper
i can't talk i'm terrified that it's not
gonna be rolled correctly and then when
she breads it it's like fall apart in
their hands it's going to be a huge mess
do you want to use not yet i think
that's the one thing i forgot about
plastic wrap used to be my favorite
thing in like
high school but it's just like
me and all my clingy relationships you
know it starts off cute and then before
you know it you're a mumbled mess trying
to rip your life apart all right well
that doesn't work that was a waste of my
time let's try another method no no
this has been the hardest part so far so
if this isn't tight it's going to be a
mess like the cheese is going to leak
into the oil it might start splattering
so then
i roll her
very tight
then we tootsie roll the tip and then
i'm going to put her in the switch
actually
i
think are you using your i think i have
to use my interjection this this could
work but i am afraid of it falling apart
because it has to be very very tight so
what i would do is after you have rolled
it what i would probably do is like kind
of
move this and i would cut the piece of
plastic wrap right and you want a lot i
gotta have too much then not enough and
put down flat right good job and then
actually let's take a second piece
and we'll put it right next to it and
take this one side and fold it over tuck
it as tight as possible and finish the
roll
yep really really tight yeah yep yep yep
and you're going to like roll it so it's
like like that and then that's going to
get really tight like a tootsie roll
take the ends and tie them together so
it stays together yep
i mean i can't touch it but it looks
good enough and um into the fridge so it
can rest that's my step that's my one
time interview damn daniel
all right i'm gonna go grab my children
from the pool
let's deep fry them
i gotta take her out of the wrapping
paper now i'm gonna dip her in here
then matt told me you gotta dip her in
here
and then we got a breader
oh she feel crunchy
dipper back in here
and we're double breading
and then
[Music]
we're gonna deep fryer
ta-da
all right i'm a little nervous to fry
and i'm not gonna move so i will be very
stiff from here on out
i know that matt has to show his
co-workers this dish as if he made it i
have to be on my game
she looks good i'm flipping it i'm
confident in myself because you know you
don't want to burn you know you need
that perfect color so i got the oven at
350 and once this is my perfect color
then we're good to go and i'll bake it
all right let's make the sauce so first
butter
[Music]
there we go
and then i'm going to do like all tasty
videos too and i'm going to spread it
around and then they like to like do
like one word slides the garlic is
supposed to get smelly so
that's all the only part of my notes
that i have left i'm smelling the garlic
and that's the last information that i
have retained and it's i need the sauce
to be perfect okay so
what the heck do i do oh you're lost now
take your opportunity okay okay um so
once you're smelling the garlic and the
butter is melted we're gonna add in the
flour
and then start to whisk it into the
butter okay looks good and then you can
add your milk
okay and once it's very thick you can
add in your parmesan cheese your dijon
mustard and your seasoning salt and
pepper so that it will be a beautiful
thick creamy mustardy cheesy sauce all
right so this is thick this is creamy
and damn doesn't smell good
so the chicken is done the sauce is
beautiful and ready to pour we got some
broccoli and some mashed potatoes on the
side so i'm gonna pick her up
oh she's not hot at all perfect
temperature
that's a little bit of a spiral
look at that spiral
no the crust came off not good okay it's
okay i'll just put it back on
it's like a weave you know this is so
cool it's just like making something
creating something like putting hard
work into something that you eat makes
you like yourself way more here's my
beautiful child that i present to the
world and now i'm gonna cheese her i am
done
woo
wow i'm impressed
so we just tried the food we're both
really happy with it but we're gonna go
see what the rest of the tasty office
thinks by going to tasty leftovers our
chat room and what should we say joyce
calling all of tasty office
oh god
please try
the greatest caught on blue who knows
that you have ever seen in your whole
entire life witness the flavor oh no the
sauce
and the parsley
it is my greatest work yet and uh please
let me know what you think like this
could ruin my reputation if they don't
like it i think the office will think
that matt made it because i have faith
in myself and i have faith in math
here it is
enjoy it this is fishy to me why are you
do you be trustful
[Music]
i don't trust you
you don't trust me whose hand is in the
frame
joyce made this
that's my girl
it's good i'm so proud of you look at
that
it was amazing i
am so proud of myself like it looked
good it tasted good going downstairs and
watching people eat food that you made
with your bare hands
it was like really humbling this is
extremely impressive so joyce more than
passed the test i could not be more
proud of her
you